Harvard professor of law Alan Dershowitz
is one of the most distinguished and
certainly one of the most famous
liberals in this country increasingly
though he doesn't seem to have much of a
home left on the left because he refuses
to participate in dogmatic attacks on
the president
Dershowitz has sharply criticized the
Muller investigation for instance he
says that anti Trump hostility is
justifying attacks on civil liberties
that threaten all of us for saying that
he says his liberal friends don't invite
him to dinner parties anymore and some
bark at him professor Dershowitz joins
us tonight professor thanks for coming
on that I was struck by this story your
account of this because you've taken
unpopular really unpopular positions
some that I disagree with over the years
and you haven't had this problem no
what's the difference well it's Trump
Trump changes everything just yesterday
on Martha's Vineyard there was a dinner
party to which I was not my wife and I
were not invited but apparently I was
the subject of the entire conversation
people asking what's happened to
Dershowitz why is he turned to the right
and I wish I had been there because I
would have pointed my finger at my
liberal friends and said it's all your
fault if you had worked as hard for the
election of Hillary Clinton as I did and
if she had been elected and they were
trying to impeach or charge her I'd be
saying exactly the same things in
defense of her rights as I did in
defense of the rights of Bill Clinton
and also in the defense of the rights of
Richard Nixon going back to the 1973
well I haven't changed I have not
changed they have so just as a reference
point you were involved in the defense
for a little while anyway of OJ Simpson
who I think is credibly accused of
murdering two people with a knife when
you went to Martha's Vineyard during
those years 95 90 60 people attacked you
at dinner parties for that a little bit
but not as much as this it's never been
like this and this time you know it
includes some of my relatives as I said
the only thing that hurts me is that up
until now people who are my relatives
would tell me oh people come over to you
and say you're related to Alan
Dershowitz Wow now they say you're
related to Alan Dershowitz how can you
justify insane
about Donald Trump so it affects my
relatives and that hurts me I have a
thick skin I've been doing this for
years I've developed the thickest skin
imaginable by the way a lot of the
tweets that I get hundreds of tweets and
messages a lot of them not only focus on
what I've been saying about the
constitutional rights of Donald Trump
but they related to me being pro-israel
and Jewish and making anti-semitic thing
out of it as well and so you know
there's not only some too much
anti-semitism on the right there's quite
a bit of it on the anti-trump left as
well I'm feeling I've noticed that so I
mean you've been at this for I don't
wouldn't even want to guess half a
century an awfully long time at this
kind of forefront of the civil
libertarian left has that group shrunk I
mean is it not just trumpet maybe the
left is less interested in traditional
civil liberties than it used to shrunk
there are no civil libertarians left on
the left
certainly not the American Civil
Liberties Union they were the ones who
said that the raid on Cohen's office
taking his lawyer client files was a
good thing not even suggesting what I
suggested and what was ultimately
adopted by the judge to have a judicial
monitor going through all of these
emails the ACLU is dead in the water
when it comes to defending the civil
liberties of people who they don't agree
with and that's just awful there are
still some civil libertarians left but
you can count them on one hand
everybody has to pass the shoe on the
other foot test if the shoe were on your
foot would you be taking the same
position you're taking today I pass that
test there are some others who pass that
test but too many both on the right and
on the left is the test if Hillary
Clinton had been elected a lot of the
people who are supporting me in
defending me on the right would be
attacking me for criticizing the
prosecution or the impeachment of
Hillary Clinton we need neutral
principles we need standards of
constitutionality that are apolitical
and I read accept to allow partisan
politics to preempt my views on the
Constitution which might have stayed the
same for 50 years
amen
when when the FBI broke into the Gmail
account of that creepy Governor Eliot
Spitzer I defended that creepy Governor
Eliot Spitzer he's my [ __ ] assistant
Eliot no it's totally wrong what they
did to him and it's important to us
professor thank you great to see you
likewise